So I do want to mention before
we move on to something else
that privacy I've said in
a individual's ability to control.
But it doesn't just have
to apply to individuals.
There may be reasons for
universities, hospitals,
charities, or even political action
committees sometimes don't need to
tell the rest of us who's contributing
to their cause and whatever.
So when you talk about privacy you
focus a lot on the individual and
their ability but it also applies to
organizations and some of those examples
we have here either because they want
to protect date about people who
are affiliated with those
organizations as their employees or
are their employees and
things like that.
So, although privacy we largely
talked about individual,
but we should keep in mind that
it also applies to organizations.